we have the story from timcast.com
Fox News founder Rupert Murdoch pushed
for Tucker Carlson's ousting Murdoch was
reportedly cornered over the former Fox
News hosts oh I'm sorry concerned what
am I doing Murdoch was reportedly
concerned over the former Fox News
House's coverage of the capital Riot on
January 6th
Murdoch uh the former Fox News host
departures allegedly related to a
discrimination lawsuit filed last month
by former producer Abby grossbert
Carlson senior second of producer Justin
Wells has also been let go the Fox News
Representatives did not further comment
grossberg who hooked on Sunday morning
features with Maria butteromo claimed
she was bullied and subjected to
anti-semitic comments after being placed
in Tucker Carlson tonight Carlson
previously reported on the capital Riot
noting Ray Epps who was president of the
capital on January 6 may be a government
informant abscess since claimed he has
been scrutinized and received death
threats following Carlson's reporting
the FBI reportedly told 60 Minutes Epps
has never worked for the agency for the
LA Times I think um
I don't know I don't know exactly what
they said but I think the FBI statement
of 16 minutes was like Weasley weasel
words like the question is was he
informing for you or taking any
instruction from you and they gave this
he has never been an employee was this
one Ted Cruz was asking questions
oh I'm so sorry I'm so sorry yeah but uh
so here's what what may be a factor here
they're saying January 6 coverage I
think specifically it's possible this is
somewhat related to the Dominion lawsuit
not directly indirectly in that they're
like we don't want to get sued again
don't go around accusing people of being
Federal informants or or things like
that that may be a factor in Tucker
Carlson's ousting but I do think it's
important to point out let's read this
headline from The Daily Mail Tucker
Carlson blindsided by Fox News firing
that was a direct order from Rupert
Murdoch after January 6 conspiracy
claims and producers lawsuit alleged
bullying sexism and anti-Semitism and
his exit erases 500 million in value I
think it's a I think it went up to a
billion from on their stock yeah so I
mean the important thing to point out is
that um uh Tucker was our only real
competition and with his ousting Tim
cast IRL we're going to the Moon maybe
that's why I came back I wasn't going to
come here I was telling Tim I would be
here and I wanted to leave him high and
dry but then once Tucker got fired I was
like this is opportunity that's right he
Sheamus is like bro I can literally do
my impression of him all the time and
people won't even know the difference
well now he doesn't want you to know
this but you can just watch Tim cast if
you want to see Tucker actually it's
better than AI exactly exactly
I do feel like this has the vibe of
McDonald's uh deciding that it's not
going to sell the Big Mac anymore
because some people get sick from it
like they have lost so much money Tucker
Carlson has such a big following how can
they possibly fill this void now dude
honestly you know again the reason why
he may or may not have been fired aside
I think that this is incredible for
Tucker Carlson and for Independent Media
as a whole to be quite honest for you
because we already all knew that cable
news was dead gen Z the average human
being is not getting their news uh you
know from mainstream media anymore to be
quite honest with you it's all coming
from Twitter I mean I've only ever
watched Tucker Carlson segments on
Twitter to be quite honest with you so I
really don't think that this is going to
impact him very much if he's only going
to get bigger we all know that and uh
yeah good luck to Fox News after this
because they just completely destroyed
themselves I hope you're right I don't
know that I'm so optimistic I think
you're right about Fox News destroying
themselves but part of what concerns me
is that there are millions of people in
this country who still believe believe
that the dominant media culture has any
credibility and they really do believe
that Fox News sets the standard for
acceptable conservative discourse and
with Tucker Carlson leaving well I do
agree he certainly doesn't need Fox to
stay afloat I'll still watch him you'll
still watch him the young audience who
likes him will his legitimacy isn't
going to be given or his uh ideas aren't
going to appear to have the same
legitimacy to an older audience I mean
it makes me wonder if he'll go
completely independent or if he'll move
to like Newsmax right because there are
President yeah I mean that would be even
more fun here's the thing I hope you're
right I hope you're right and Tucker
just continues to grow and blow up the
thing that people don't realize right
with Fox News as they exist is while CNN
is the network that tells you what
you're supposed to believe Fox is the
network that tells you what you're
allowed to believe you might not like
the flavor CNN is offering and so here's
the outer limit over here of what you're
allowed to voice and believe in what
Tucker Carlson did is he moved the
Overton window they had there more
towards the direction of
anti-establishment true truth speaking
as opposed to catering to the vision of
what conservatives should be that the
establishment right has been trying to
promote for decades well yeah a fox like
Hannity is you know he's the guy who
says the the the big things that control
stuff are bad so you should just sit
there and and listen to me yell about it
so that they can keep doing whatever
they want and then Tucker Carlson is
like you know actually they shouldn't be
doing that and here's an alternate
Theory this is one thing that
conservatives really struggled with in
media is what fox will do and what a lot
of these right-wing pundits will do is
they will poke holes in the media
narrative but they won't offer a counter
narrative and so when we have Tucker
Carlson talking about January 6th and
Ray apps what he's essentially doing is
filling in the gaps for people he's
saying here's this guy who we saw
inciting arguably allegedly right we
have the footage of it that's not
alleged but whether that's something he
would be prosecuted with inciting
violence for is another story however
what a traditional Fox News host might
say is we'll look at all of these holes
in the left's narrative but they
wouldn't say here's the alternate
explanation and in fact they would say
anyone who promotes that alternate
explanation is a far-right lunatic and
I'm not one of those guys Tucker Carlson
was actually willing to give you
substance aside from the left is wrong
agreed yeah I think he did bring forward
a lot of topics and like you said points
that we would not have normally heard
from a Hannity maybe even from olora
Ingram a lot of people talking about too
how Jesse Waters maybe the only last
person at Fox News that people could
really trust who could maybe even follow
Tucker Carlson so yeah you know this is
going to be a big hit like you said to
the older generation that does still
look to the mainstream media and view
them as a legitimate source of news
um we'll see what happens in the future
but you know like I said I think that
this is actually a good thing I'm look
I'm trying to look at the positives of
this you know what I mean just with like
uh Tucker leaving fox now we know the
corporate media is a laughing stock
nobody trusts them Elon is taking over
Twitter now independent journalism is
really thriving uh so yeah I've been
black pilled about a lot in the nation
and so I think that you know I'm just
I'm excited about where we're at in
regards to Independent journalism and
the freedom that people now have to be
able to tell the truth a little bit a
little bit more take a look at this
story from Politico it's interesting
Tucker Carlson's exit shows who who's
the real star at Fox no one is
irreplaceable and they they want to make
the stupidest argument I've ever heard
that Glenn Beck wasn't the star in 2009
when he generated the largest viewership
in the 5 PM hour Bill O'Reilly wasn't
blah blah blah they're arguing that fox
will easily replace Tucker Carlson in
the 8 PM slot and I gotta tell you they
will not no they've already they've
already tried doing um I can't remember
what for what what show it was they had
one slot recently in the past year
whatever where they were doing rotating
series of guest house trying to figure
out who would be a good personality and
it didn't go anywhere Tucker Carlson
is the guy right yeah dude and even when
he's absent right there's no clear oh
when Tucker's out we definitely want
this this person and they haven't been
able to successfully audition somebody
to inherit the slot so now they fired
him they haven't even given him a
transition schedule to leave and they're
going to do what with it who are they
going to call up from the the the uh
From the Bench to to fix this that's
what I'm saying I feel like Tucker was
Top Dog he wasn't afraid to talk about
things and the great thing about Tucker
too is that he would go and speak to and
platform the smaller independent
journalists who had substantial stories
I remember when I was at the uh 2022
NCAA Women's swimming Championship
Twitter had deleted the clip of the
first athlete that spoke out against
Leah Thomas uh it wasn't uh Riley Gaines
or the other athlete who had spoken out
but it was this young Virginia Tech
swimmer named Rose Tucker picked up her
interview he is the one that made that
you know really big Twitter ended up
censoring and deleting the clip but you
know that's just an example of how
Tucker has been at the Forefront of of
like helping the little man and helping
the average American and that's why he's
popular because your average mainstream
media head doesn't care about the uh you
know the actual American public they
don't care about what we are going
through in this country they care about
sharing their talking points uh Tucker
was the exact opposite of that and there
really is no other pundit that can
compare in the mainstream yeah and
that's also part of why I was saying
earlier I really do think this is bad
for us we've been deprived of something
Tucker having that platform on national
television and being able to tell the
story of these female athletes who have
been deprived of what they should have
had the opportunity to do because Leah
Thomas was competing in their Sports was
massive two voters 55 and up that that's
that's what we're losing
in addition to YouTube the way that the
younger audience people who are
interested in Tucker well exactly and
look at who the abiding Administration
is targeting right now it's gen Z with
all of these dumb tick talkers now and
it is this next Generation that is going
to be leading this country that is going
to be leading uh you know us into where
we're going to be going as a country
guess I articulated that horrible but
yeah that's why I'm like okay let's lose
the Boomer audience all right like we
need to be focusing on the younger
people and I think that uh Tucker has
that big phone and he can do that with
the amount of Independent Media we have
I certainly don't disagree that Tucker
is going to be fine on his own and I
hope that his audience is going to
continue to grow I am just a little bit
cautious and I'm a little bit skeptical
that he's going to be able to build the
kind of platform that we would like to
see him have given how hard big Tech
clamps down on anyone who speaks the
truth and I hope that's true and look
I'm on Rumble now too for my podcast I
think they're a great platform I hope
they're able to reach some kind of deal
I do like your optimism but I will still
say I think the American people were
deprived of something I think it's very
sad he was basically the only person on
cable television saying anything right
like you said the other news anchors
give you talking points this is a threat
to democracy or that was racist and
xenophobic they'll just regurgitate
these lines they've heard someone else
say and Tucker would say something can
you give me an example of something say
Hannity said in the past few months no I
can't give you an example of something
happened to anybody in the room I will
look because I'm not I'm not a boomer I
don't really watch cable television I'll
tune in every now and again but it's
pretty rare for me I get most of my
information from the internet and the
sources I find to be credible there I
just want you to know that you're
insulting a lot of Boomers in the chat
listen listen no offense to the good
Boomers some of them I assume are good
people right but my parents are in that
generation my parents are in that
generation too and I think Tucker
Carlson did a fantastic work when he was
on Fox the Boomers gave us Star Trek the
Next Generation that's also true it's
fantastic that is true that's like one
of the very few things but if that's
like the only thing then but even that
was a spin-off of something I mean Gene
Roddenberry wasn't a boomer right
that's that's a spin-off from the
original Star Trek from the 60s yeah so
and they made it better
there's a whole huge debate to have
there we're not gonna get the We're not
gonna get into that controversial
territory here on timcast what if Fox
brings on Don Lemon now and he takes the
eight o'clock it actually the thing is
it wouldn't sound that different
University but Fox wouldn't sound that
different if they brought Don Lemon on
that's what bothers me they're all so
they're all saying the same thing
interchangeable we gotta mention that
dude was fired but first I want to talk
about this story can I just make one
more Point really quickly about this so
they're saying what you said hit the
nail on the head right they think Tucker
is going to be replaceable because
everyone else on television is all of
these other personalities are it is not
going to be easy to replace Tucker
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time